[Music]
this year the leading republican running
for governor
is a uh the closest thing
to a trump
clone that i've ever seen in your state
california
keep gavin newsom and send a message to
the nation
well there he is president biden heading
to california to defend embattled
governor
gavin newsom as voters at the polls in
the golden state today fox nation host
tommy lahren joins us now tommy doesn't
joe biden's visit just reinforce this
notion that it's really the washington
elite that want to prop up gavin newsom
and want him in there in the first place
and not the common folk
well it's not just the washington elite
of course it's the hollywood elite it's
the big tech elite it's a special
interest like the almighty teachers
union all of the elites they were able
to really weather the pandemic and
whether coveted tyranny that gavin
newsom placed on that state they're all
the ones that are propping up gavin
newsom saying that they want to keep him
in the state because they are the ones
that really haven't been affected by his
disastrous leadership but it's the
average people on both the left and the
right in california who were saying you
know what the failed leadership of gavin
newsom is not good for the golden state
we have the fifth largest economy in the
world it's about time we start acting
like it so the la times their editorial
board came out with a piece defending
gavin newsom they say the many reasons
to vote no on recalling governor gavin
newsom they go on to say many people are
mad about how the pandemic upended their
lives but that's not newsome's fault
and punishing him will not fix anything
in fact it will likely make things worse
for everyone in the state would love for
you to respond to that
yeah this is what democrats do they
cannot take accountability for anything
that they've done and even if you don't
believe that the horrible leadership of
gavin newsom through the pandemic was
problematic you have to look at
california pre-pandemic before the first
coveted case was ever recorded in that
state you still didn't have great things
and that's what the la times also cannot
outline they're not talking about how
great he has handled the homeless crisis
how great he has enforced the border how
he has decreased lawlessness and felon
coddling in his state how he's lowered
gas prices and red tape and regulations
they're not touting any of that because
it doesn't exist his leadership was bad
before the pandemic it worsened during
the pandemic and it became impossible to
ignore because of covet but make no
mistake gavin's leadership was worse and
now but it was bad
many many years ago when he was in
charge of san francisco and democrats
have been ruining that state for years
it's time to make a change not just with
gavin newsom but with the democrat
leadership of that state that has failed
that state
meantime joe biden's vaccine mandates
criticized at a time when so many
americans refuse to work get this the
white house saying that a hundred
million americans will be affected by
joe biden's vaccine mandate what's your
message to those hundred million tommy
what's your message to the white house
as well
my message to those hundred million plus
americans right now who are sitting in a
position where they're having to either
get a vaccine or lose their job now let
me be clear if you want to get the
vaccine because you believe it's the
best decision for your health and your
safety and that's your personal decision
that you have made with your doctor then
that is one thing but if you are simply
getting the vaccine to keep your job
that is wrong that is unamerican but can
we really be surprised we started
hemorrhaging our rights to the
government over a year and a half ago
and now they continue to take you give
them an inch they will take a mile these
mandates are unconstitutional i hope
that they will be challenged and to the
biden white house please understand this
for many folks the religious exemption
is that they believe in jesus christ
they believe in their personal health
and their personal choices and freedom
they don't believe in government and
they don't believe in fouchy and they're
going to make their decisions for
themselves so the response should be we
will see you in court yeah well a lot of
republican governors already said uh
that very thing no surprise there um
they were having this fair conversation
on msnbc about the vaccine mandate and
one of their hosts stephanie ruehl said
that it shouldn't be hard to follow
because all you have to do is this take
take a listen
if you do not want to get vaccinated you
can work from home you can homeschool
your children you can shop online so
where is this coming from people saying
i'm now being forced to be vaccinated
so it's easy tommy just work from home
shop online never leave your house
i'm going to provide a counterpoint to
that how about this if after over a year
and a half if you are still afraid of
coronavirus you
can stay home the rest of us are going
to go about living our normal lives
we're going to go to work we're going to
go to school we're going to have family
gatherings we're going to go to football
games and we're going to live normally
and if that terrifies you you're the one
that can stay home as for the rest of us
we're going to be free americans in this
free country that we live in also for
the jobs that you can't work from home
at those are the ones we need to filter
so to say we can just everybody can work
for a construction worker can they work
from home can a chef in a restaurant
work from home kind of tough and maybe
not wear masks outside in the great
outdoors
pointless tommy thank you so much for
joining us today we appreciate it it is
a tommy tuesday night this is tommy
tuesday thank you thanks tommy and with
that